Like the whole fucking game is like every question is the same which is like, you know
But how and I'm like fight we need how there is no, right? There's only make it
Like making over being right and by like who gets to decide if it's right
People confuse like how would I do that? Is this how would I do it?
Is that just make it but how do I make a tik tok ? I don't fucking dance to music
I'm like then don't dance to music
Twitter didn't start out this way facebook didn't start out this way
Instagram didn't started this way shit involves you do you into the platform
It's not what is the platform doing currently and I conformed to it fuck platform filled with your shit. I
Got this shit from the traffic you bags my pin in my pan bad. Daddy got rich off for a few thrown
We sending them back that shit as a fact my junk Wayne got no ID on him
He had to sit through the back go on the man. They took everything he had off his body
Thought he was late cause he ran. I've got a hustle, but we don't get back he broke
Go public looks good. It's scary beans complex con old five
Come drop 110 flippin for 300 on stock action trying to let me make some money
I'm fucked on over 5 1 any advice very young entrepreneur
Of course in the creative space, of course
patience
Fuckin reverse engineer what you actually want to be doing and like it's all about keeping it quiet in your head
I'm just fuckin working. The problem is everybody's just spending too much time listening
You're sure I'm not doing option and it's like it takes a long time to build real shit. I agree
I'm like, it shouldn't take a year to build something meaningful
I completely agree that I always tell my friend and everybody's like it takes too long right now
I'm building in having social media pop him. Everybody told me it's too much. You can't do it on your own
Even if you fucking lose the experience is more valuable than not trying. That's what I said
It's all having serie hundred percent like so much you can do in school pleasure. Well, that's fucking cool
That's fucking fresh. Actually. I think this is a fresh fucking execution. Yeah, this is a fucking fresh execution. I like this. I
Bet you like this
Real good nice treat your brother
I'm an artist my goal is to like, you know be one. Yep guys here
I'm having the hardest time like growing my audience right now
I'm just trying to find a job to like get my I just moved along
Max out my credit card all that course, so
Jim the advice for the cotton growing audience ask artists
Doing new platforms. I really think tik toks a big play. I really do. You know, I'm yelling about it
Yeah, everybody's in the know business
You every other people everyone's like no this will work for me and I'm like no no, yes
Right tick tock is the one place where you can do a piece of content and have four million people see it
Yeah when you have eight fuckin followers, right? Okay. I don't really know anything about it figure it out
I'm just trying to think of leg because I've been hearing you say that I'm like
How would I do that as an artist like feeling yourself making shit?
Just put a photo hold the fucking thing up and just fucking put it over music. I don't give a fuck. Okay
Sorry, thank you so much. You got another chit it take care. Thank you, brother. Yeah, go pop adapting. Sorry girl
I seen you talk to murder beats erotic problem tell you right now tick tock is the one place
Where you get up eight fucking followers being a fucking garage in Cleveland post one video and have the number one song in America
That's fun hurt
People don't get it. We got one by accident like the
Follow up like we just put the shit outta me and then it started going on tick tock you can have a song
Yeah
like Tears for Fears
Could happen the number one song in America by making something like somebody doing a dance on things like it's I'm glad you caught that
Figure it out don't care about what people think fucking hit it. It's free exposure and fucking awareness is the only way you can win
How do you have nice to meet you wrong to meet you better I'm working with cases for the last nine months
I'm an influencer for them. What can you recommend me? Should I continue more like this this way like natural? Yeah in my content
Yes, should I pay for home whenever?
listen paying for
AB step bring of new fans is smart paying for people who just like it is not smart as nuts much the other thing you
Have to absolutely do is get serious about to talk
Hey guys, sorry to interrupt your video. I'm just giving you this call for my number
To let you know that you have to join my text community
To 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 hit me up with a text
Yeah, ha actually had offered me when they first open in there were offering me a percentage to get and you have to get serious
about tick tock tick tock
Now if I go say the same thing brothers 300 you have to make three tic TOCs a day starting tomorrow
It's real people don't get it
Instagrams organic reach is going to continue to go down
Tick-tock, you can have four followers post one time at half a million people watch it
You need to get serious about 6f right now right this second you understand
You know the key is the number one thing that happens when something new happens when somebody wanted the old thing they say no
Instead of saying yes
You help me like steal my life, bro
I'm 21, right? I sell jewelry dude on Instagram. I started like 5 KB
I've been watching us like a year now. Are you going hard a tic toc?
I want take talk I go like 3,000 followers by like how many how off tell me the truth?
How often you post in the day on tick tock right once every week or two weeks, bro
It's messed up bro. It's messed up. I know dude it's but like but like its Martin no, no 8020 big
No, no way. Nothing like 80% of your profits count like
100% of your clock
Sleep five hours a day and go hard
Dude, that's not I want to know what if you're telling me the reason you can't post on sick time two times a day
It's because you're spending all your time and Instagram. I want to know what the fuck you're doing every 24 hours
I want to know how you're sleeping
I want to know what content you're consuming how you're living most like almost a hundred pieces of content just from you feel like I'm
Living breathing this and it's like with like listen me the tick tock
Here's what Instagram can do for you that tick tock at 10
You can make one tick tock video and it flashed in your shit and you can get 5 million organic views overnight. I
Fucking feel that and literally tick tock is like you folks funny
You can post like it's that it like so what's the problem tell me?
Insecurity like good like that. The kids are even too young for you kind of shit, dude
They naughty baby was like I love I love cream
So what about tick tock Dylan's looked as corny a little bit to some people whore with me
I remember when you say that was corny until it's not and I would that's my motto of like fuck this place
fuck all these cool kids from every one of these cooler colors in your
Fucking leg fucking approach. It's not corny. It's gonna be the fucking framework do it is the framework wrong. I know it is
That's why I sang ton of me cuz it already in ik talkies are living like living proof of that
Okay, well you need to post two times a day on tick tock
Hey
I think this is what just did it like obviously writing my actions are but I need to do that because I thought your producer
Do it. It's Who I
Am very aware, of course
Okay
Grayson
Number one, I think self-awareness
you
Know whether your youngster or an old guy like me
The reality is if you don't know who you are, if you don't know what you're good at
It's very hard to be successful. Number two is patience
It's the biggest problem that people have with success. They want it now. They want it now
They want it now and that leads to number three, which is close your ears
I think one of the biggest ways to be successful is to not listen to other people's opinions
sure, you take feedback, but most people are in the know business and
It's very hard to achieve something when you've said no before you've even started
So those are my three tips
How are you bro, how's it going you look at fresh bro, what's been going on? You been hustling? Yeah
How old are you now
Eleven. Yeah, it's amazing breath house. Cool
Yeah, we do. Well, it's easy. Yeah
And they are
Learning new stuff every day
Lousy to selfie
Take advantage of my good nature I try and give unlife and
If you're actually giving you can't be taken advantage of because I have no
It's the fucking answer everyday. People are like Gary you're wrong
It's not good to be kind or to give people take advantage of you like you're wrong
You weren't giving you were setting something else up. I know I'm right giving is clean
I've never feel like you were to take advantage of me and by the definition of many people I'm being taken advantage of
150 times in a second
no, because I'm giving
People that care are looking for something in return
The end which is not the definition of giving it's a definition of either
manipulation
Strategy or some sort of movements. That is a very definitive
massive part of this conversation
Gary but my kindness I get run over. No, you know
You're allowing that run over to happy because you're looking for something
Thank you, you're welcome now on the flip side, this is important
It's okay to do something with expectation, but you better fucking change that to strategy. Are you gonna say it overnight? You gotta own?
That's called negotiate. Yeah, you understand
No, never be taken advantage again over if you actually break it into giving and negotiate
So one college and everything got in
Yep
My dad and I do mug life all that shit. Oh, thank you
What's your advice? Like?
While having the pressure of all that shit, you know, the reality is you have to put it into decade
Windows instead of one year windows. Okay. You're young
young shit you really really are and so like all of a sudden if you think about being out of debt at
47 and still knowing that's youngest fuck
Yeah, all of a sudden it doesn't feel as daunting right instead of thinking about it today and decide it all crash on
You know a hundred percent now you put it into a 10 or 20 year window 37 or 40 to about 43
Like you're 16 years away from that
So instead of being like here's what everybody does with college debt, they'd well that they did it, right
Like I don't regret my experience at all. I loved it
You just you still regret having the debt exactly
it's taking the debt is the regret and the dwelling and throwing it over here and just
Focusing on the effects. That's it
It is what happened? No different than somebody being born with the disease. No different than somebody losing a parent
Everybody's got something right this thing that's like that
Every second you spend on your college debt is a second that you're not spending on winners
So it's putting into a 20-year window
You're gonna live for a really long fucking time, yeah
Like if you're 28, you're gonna live for another 80 years
The number one disease for everybody is lack of patience
Lack of patience. Everybody wants it now to prove to somebody that they made it
Everybody values other people's opinions
Instead of aiming for happiness. Do you know what's going on here a bunch of people are buying dumb shit
To make themselves feel better. Yeah
That's what's happening here. That is what is happening here
A bunch of people are running around buying dumb shit to make it look like they're happy
And then there's a small percentage my favorite percentage of people running around here buying dumb shit to flip to make money
Which I appreciate yes
Honestly on some real shit
Like there's a lot of people here
Complaining about college debt and the system's fucked and they're buying $800 sneakers to put on to make it look like they're happy
Right people are fucking bull full of shit. Like honestly, we need accountability
We need to get back to accountability
It's real like everybody feels like there's some systemic shit that's shitting on them
The system's been but not forget about America the world the internet
This is the greatest generation to be alive the greatest the greatest
there are people running around here who had an idea and
Decided to print some shit on a t-shirt and now we're making it like people like that wasn't real in 1965
so
People need to talk to old people
I'm old but I'm talking old. I'm talking like 8090 like we need perspectives like
my last part is
You're going to live a long time
Get patient you guys decades today make you dream happy
I'm really gonna miss this place. Thank you, brother
Tyler's make me take photos with dumb fucking dolls. I don't give a fuck if it's his doll the actual Dom
Short stick
Keep going
fuck
Babban, don't film this it's devastating. Alright filming. It's funny Wow. Keep going in. That's right there
That's that not see it a little hot. Yep. Yeah
Who anymore did you more aunt? I had the fly this hurts so fucking bad. Yep shit
Shit. Keep go ahead super important. Yo, Andy
Right here
Fresh Gary, thank you for I'm excited about him Tyler elbow me like straight elbow, right?
What's up, bro right here
Thank you, bro. I'm true. Like dude, you know, you're fucking old and fucked up and your fucking neck hurts right there down
right that that
Yes up and out higher
Higher
And I
Know what I'm doing because I get this not a lot
time
Over here. Yeah, that's it. That's it. Break my fucking back up higher higher
That's good touch
More that that right there ties
That right there. Yep, you feel it. That's it. Tyler's got a guy's toes got a catch
Like probably got about Sonic to do with that